today's Riata is as much a social
experiment as it is a race Clash of
character old money versus no money at
all six boats of want toos against one
filled with have twos and these nine
working class boys arrive from the
American West on the shoulders of a
country that sees itself in their
determined young faces sees their
struggles their grit their spirit and
they've claimed the Husky Clipper as
their own the boys in the boat were
strong tough kids but they were poor and
hungry they're rowing because was the
only way they could stay in college well
what's that about making some money yeah
the rowing team you R you get a
part-time job included she place to live
all you got to do is make the team I'm
coach irson now you're all here because
we're looking for the eight most
qualified young men to fill out
JV there's basically three major races
and we knew that the first one has to be
a surprise and then the third one has to
be a whole other level the second race
was about grit KY rat is always always
most important race out the season it
was about these guys digging down deep
these guys who really had nothing it's
also a race that the University of
Washington has not won in almost two
decades the importance of this race is
that it is the qualifying race to get
into the Olympics but we have a boat
that I believe could change all
that that boat is our Junior boat have
you lost your
mind rowing particularly in the 1920s
was one of the most attended Sports from
the United States hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of people would go to these
races or rickon puts the JV boat ahead
of the VAR City team because they're
fast they're a faster boat and it's all
about winning my job to put the best
boat in the water your job I pay for
your job his job's online it's a
depression all those coaches and if they
don't win they're going to lose the job
you send a boat full of kids down there
and they trip up you're sticking your
neck way out there but if he loses
he made the wrong choice the school
doesn't go to the Olympics the stakes
for him are really really high but he
takes that risk because these young guys
are hungrier go up until the pyy race
Joe's just going through the motions or
brickson kicks him out of the boat
because his head's spinning and he's not
concentrating he's not being a team
member the thing about rowing is that
everybody has to be in Sy you have to
row as one all right here we go
boys
and it starts you know as a fair
everybody's happy there's a lot of
people enjoying a lovely weekend by the
water find your place by the River or
the radio hearing the radio announcer
and we're seeing the seriousness of our
guys I think that makes us as an
audience think can they do it this time
Che for guts and heart and Brawn to beat
privilege and Prestige to the finish
line today Martin and Matt and George
and me and then with the editing and the
music you know we had to create
basically out of whole cloth this
sequence
the starting gun is up ORS to front
stops nearly 100,000 Spectators hold
their breath in anticipation all the
other races are basically on lakes and
this was on a river so we wanted to give
it that scope that feeling and then size
this is also the longest race in
distance so we had to build that length
we shot it on a water reservoir near hro
airport I'm not exaggerating every
minute a jumbo jet would take off and
Fly Right Grand would be like you know
all right this is a British Air going to
Bali go and we shoot in between we have
like a maybe 30second window literally
that we could do dialogue between big
loud ples fortunately a lot of that
stuff didn't have
dialogue to create Hudson River around
that was was a big challenge there's
nothing around it there's everything
that you see on that screen didn't exist
I did the second unit on the film so I I
did that shot oh yeah all the foreground
stuff is there but once the camera Rises
up it's all fake it's just so much fun
that was a race where thousands of
people were watching and they had trains
along the coastline where people could
travel with the teams and then watch
them we shot everything on the train on
a parking lot near the studio we built
two cars and green screen and then
background extras and our cast and then
visual effects takes that and does their
magic to it it's all an illusion because
we couldn't find any other place to
shoot it quite
frankly I'd say the biggest challenge on
the making of the film from my
perspective and I know from George's
perspective and I think from Martin's
perspective too was trying to make
rowing as exciting as possible C still
showing no signs of slowing down
Washington is getting its first taste of
competition something coach Alon can
hope to build on we spent weeks on the
water before we started filming it took
about a week to sort of figure out how
to shoot the boats like how to get to
the right place to feel right got to
understand what the ins and outs of the
actual rowing
entail for the first race you know we
would start out here and the second race
we would be here when you're far back
nothing looks fast it's hard to get
close and even if you get close you know
the the row is the face is constantly
move more
shoulders down a wide shot let everybody
know where the geography is on the pipy
race we used drones but you had to find
ways to make it Dynamic I think we had
three camera boats plus two cameras for
a second unit we had one strong boat
with a super techno crane on and the
camera on that that had a strong wake so
if we were to overtake with that boat
another rowing boat we would sink we're
moving in closer to make it tighter and
closer as you got in cuz now we know
them out in front of start a tire and
you'll just be getting
start shooting on water in my experience
is the most challenging thing that I've
ever done as a filmmaker everything
slowed down I mean I did The Perfect
Storm I knew what I was getting into
when we lined up the ppy race there was
a little bit of wind then the boats
would just not be in position because
there's a current so the boats all start
moving around and they're not in
straight lines a lot of it is just
getting the guys to row in syn and
shooting theit out of it we have a lot
of cameras a lot of angles all right
give me 10 big ones for Alber
go we storyboarded the whole thing if
you look at our storyboard says they
match the action stuff exactly the way
we drew it up this was probably the most
challenging sequence for the actors in
the boat it required the most rowing
it's a really physically demanding part
for all these guys and they're just
sitting in the middle of a Reservoir in
these eight man boats it's cold it's
windy give me three big ones to finish
your there's only so much that you can
ask of them without you know breaking
them wet and cold best part of the day
right here we showed it over 5 days and
then getting into the edit and having
Tanya then take all that it's like a
almost like a puzzle really and putting
it all
together nearly 100,000 Spectators hold
their breath in anticipation a hush
falling over Crum
elbow
and here we go Washington huskys are now
rowing against the seniors of Cal huskys
are the only Junior vat in the
competition give me a nice easy 28 Vol
with done e
and these seven finally trained crews
are churning the Waters of the upper
Hudson in the Supreme rowing test of
power speed and coordination we had
three big races and we didn't want them
to feel exactly the same even though
this team their thing was kind of coming
from behind
keeping the boats in the right order
kind of telling the right story as to
who was winning at the beginning who
were who were neck and neck throughout
the race just passing the halfway point
and Washington is surging well you
better be right M we went through each
one we sort of found which race needed
what and it required a style of editing
that I'm not used to as well a lot of
the close-ups of the ores and the water
and the orlocks and you know just
textural detailed shots of hands or
close on the guys it adds the
ferociousness the nature of the race
Washington is pulling ahead 20 more
Strokes come on we just tried to make
things H have a little chaos and and a
lot more energy A much faster pace of
cutting we wanted to make sure we were
using an angle that featured the train
in the background the pypy Riata today's
Riata is the greatest one-day rowing
event in
America coaches like Kai EB Rusty callow
and Al alberon are not only hoping for a
win but a chance to compete in Berlin
there's going to be thousands of people
lining that Shoreline oh that pace Bobby
with regard to the pypy race we were
able to create not only the the race but
I think we we nailed those story Points
Washington has fallen back to last place
four lengths behind the leaders now
Bobby thing about Bobby Mack as he gets
the job done what's he doing it has to
be now come on boys wait for it the
coach gives him a little talk and then
he does the opposite wait
for all right D give me 36 go oh he's
just having a great time he has no doubt
that he's going to be able to get them
to muscle past and win and here they
come looking for fresh water Bobby Mack
is steering right into Syracuse's Lane
by the time we get to the pyy race he
really takes it to the point where you
think there's absolutely no way that
they're going to be able to make this
work get off us I go to hell Syracuse
what the hell
Washington is passing Syracuse and with
a mile and a half behind them teams are
falling away but no one is gaining on
California and navy what you can't help
but get excited when we cut back to the
girls at the college and they sitting by
the radio at the quarter Mark we've got
California pen and navy out in front
with a half Bo lead on the rest of the
field a shout out to Mark Smith who
wrote all these beautiful little beats
in there you get the sense that alberon
and his wife have a great relationship
but that she's got to poke the bear
every once in a while oh I do love your
smile
you should do it more
often these sequences without score
would be
nothing where you'll really see the
difference is when we do a temp score
and then you see his score you know
that's tied directly to the
story from the beginning I tried to with
the help of the images make the audience
feel that these eight guys they're
superheroes everybody else tired and
they just get stronger when they start
rowing I start to pulse of GrooVe and
they found their Pace the fluidity of
their
movements the winning theme that will
develop I start installing this theme as
the Roaring team gets closer to the
Finish Line 10
more 50 m and they will surpass
everybody because they are actually not
only very strong individually but
together they're like the force that you
can't stop here we go boys give me 35
let's show them what we got you really
feel like you get to know these people
you really feel the camaraderie that's
built with this team and the struggle
that they went through the average human
body is just not meant for such things
it's just not capable of such things but
average not going to get a seat on my
boat I look back at George's film he
likes to give to the audience a journey
through the life of one or few emble of
people who will have to go over hurdles
challenge themselves and show heroism
and team effort show Al brickson was in
this
book ready all of it builds a sequence
in a in in a film that hopefully
transports the audience to a place that
they've never been
before you got this it's
when you're in the boat with those guys
working so hard you believe them as one
as one it's a Cinderella Story it's
chars it's Rocky we have 100,000 race
fans gathered here for what is sure to
be another Maritime battle the likes of
which we haven't seen since New Orleans
this film reminds us that we are all in
this
[Applause]
together it's a story that is
unbelievable and it just tears at your
heart Joe your dad gave up on you he
quit on you but it seems to me you're
not him this was just about feeling good
about ourselves which is a nice thing to
[Music]
do Washington has picked up the pace
Bobby mock finally getting his crew in
this race the Husky sweeping by Cornell
headed for pen and Colombia Navy and Cal
still ahead by four L give me let's
go
Washington is quickly gaining on
Columbia's Lions better not be too
late the Husky Clipper muscles by
Columbia and into third
place now give me 10 more for B with 400
m to go here comes
Washington
20 more Strokes
[Music]
19 Washington has taken second place do
they have enough left to catch
cow Bo come on Bo come look at
Washington I don't believe what I'm
seeing can the huskys do it can they do
it give me 10 big ones for all the
people who didn't believe in you
go give me cow I want cow yeah we're
working with 200 M left Washington is
passing tow Washington is passing cow
and and one eat through eyes up with 100
m to go Washington is going to do it
Washington is going to do
it eyes up eat come
[Applause]
[Music]
on